do this thing right here and this is
what Wow like what was the set of ones
thanks to skill chair for sponsoring
this video stick around to the end to
find out how you can get two months free
you know I don't know I used to be a
visual effects guy just like you guys I
did that for five and a half years in
Dallas and then I moved out to LA in
2008 to pursue stunts I guess I'm known
to be one of those firemen doubles or
amazing spider-man before that or done
avatar pirates transformers
my specialty is fights pipes and wire
work falling out of trees or tripping
down the steps
enough
[Music]
oh I was a rural leader I was the fight
coordinator for this and I used to get a
script at first some scripts are more
detailed than others but for instance
this one was just as fireman comes in
you just beat up 40 10 people so then
what we have to do is basically
conceptualize all the in-betweens then
just make up a previous okay love these
penises or it's just a bunch of karma
box yes so they didn't have a step bill
so we had to get the blueprints we use
these boxes so we know that the size of
space that we're using to try to get as
close as possible yeah guys so this big
front door ATM machines this is a yeah
this is step so that wasn't a real ATM
that was just a space a storefront
are you actually in a storefront on
yahoo sweet so how are you reading that
the wires then it the seeing some actual
see we actually drilled holes who was
ceiling oh really
so the trust is everything with the wire
so it's inside that structure in that
structure Scottie bill that's pilots
Epson correct so the job of the guys
hitting the wall like I can't see the
pads like there's no pads in the ground
the walls look padded parlor pads
happening here is not that was just no
mystery to ground of course rehearsals
be padded up we test it to where it's
date because that wall hasn't did so
that gave them some cushion when we hit
it in that track is all CG so typically
track oh nice yeah so that's all posted
as you got to tell through this channel
we love sharing our knowledge and
learning new things there's actually a
site called Skillshare which is
dedicated to just that sticker on the
end of the video you'd like to learn
more about it I cannot believe my eyes
this thing was so difficult really
they could get the wire close enough to
the wall so I haven't like I using my
cord and just stick to that water
alright I feel like can you stick to it
more I'm like dude I'm not a real
spider-man
his costume was $40,000 Wow and they had
20 25 of them Julie this is the first
time I've ever worked off your right
thumb yeah but you can't see him do our
lines like wow this is really
uncomfortable you're here first
spider-man whoa
you have that masculine and you're doing
all these stunts you know you get so
windy so you want to be like breathe
yeah but actually restrict her breath I
did a scene with fireman guys into the
sewer water and I completely
waterboarded myself you can't hold your
breath freezing cold water you your
reflexes to go and so I went in it went
group didn't heal our water came up oh
yeah look ice water was still in my -
while I like had a homework they passed
away from my face almost ripped the
thing off
so the Sweden bridge they obviously want
me to stay forward it was like we won't
do everything pretty straight line don't
know about control you're spider-man you
should be in control of your flight and
the Tobey Maguire in spite of anyways
he's that spinner great exactly and so
we we thought that too but as we're
doing it you know Mario so you're
spinning out of control but I just went
with it and acted like I pulled right
down to my legs it shot behind you and
they loved it oh yeah that's three since
we did everything
practically they like the physics of our
movement of how things messed up is that
the invention of like the third model
spider-man style of just expanding
wildly and like I think so beside it
I've been seeing that every once in a
while I like to show you the statistics
of how many people are subscribed to his
channel and forty percent of the people
that watch these episodes currently are
not subscribed so if you like these
episodes I wanna keep watching them
instead of subscribing you'll be
notified when they come out take the
power away from me I'll really put it
into your hands
[Music]
in spite of all my hardest hits dude
shooting my parachute yeah
Sheldon dummy giving it within I came in
later to overlap it let's forget the
chicken bones now and this is me what
wow there's like okay so nobody got hit
flipped over the police car and the
wutface persons with window shield so we
need you to do that the first tape miss
the window shield you see how I hit the
top of it yeah you thought since I get
so high I missed the pad so I just wanna
straight to Congress they went with that
one these will look more gnarly I hope
you landed it like a sauna steam room
kind of situation because that is wrong
dude that's so let's take a look at one
of these famous jackets HAMP license I'm
fighting with every day I always James
Marsters Bob so much you're pitching
potential here are you Oh alright so
what about this ladder guy shot if I
were to do this you would just light
another tape you know something that's
safe and you just practice practice
until you feel like you comfortable and
then take it out put the leather let me
do it right now so your your muscle
memories there
this is Jackie Chan though you know give
this Chinese opera they're dying to do
rings and little open spaces so this is
something that he's always trained to do
it's not anything you do I believe
there's some bloopers and outtakes from
this fight scene that's where the LoVo
Jacksonville's he does all the altitudes
yeah so he is a really that's why you
practice no you're forgetting you see
some of the stuff didn't think oh man
I'm so still it took like 30 takes 370
it takes to get something right so it's
nice to see some I'll show you guys is
really hard
Crenna machines is actually one of the
most asked forces that have been named
pecans so if you guys have any stunt
scenes action movies etc that you would
love for us to react to or break down or
tell stories about please even comment
down below that's what we're about to do
right here usually guys it's a highlight
reel I just want to see your reactions
and let's talk about something like that
just like right after like on the block
came out this feeds more stuff goes yeah
that is taking it
I mean ever at least these falls on
their taking like in your experience
there is taken over like how are they
not like just cracking they're spying on
each one of these along the coordination
or is taking those different steps
obviously hitting you have to be aware
of where your body is and you have to
hit these marks how long do we do this
shot without kill your stomach sometimes
it will have a wire on them yes just the
fall so at least they know they go to
out of whack or if they're going
straight on their head they can spot
them so I guess on a wire I'm not sure
how much that it lands enough ambulance
how I would go about this you go
somewhere where it's safe and you've had
those those Heights up you just kind of
go forward with the padding you see how
your body moves and where it's going to
end up and you just do it to you feel
comfortable did you take it out so you
like okay doing yjp shoes ruling they
just put themselves through the wringer
first we get a little treat for you
wrong I'm very excited for this and I
actually have some legit questions about
this meat soda
I know that guy is this is so oh you
guys this is so good
[Music]
I've seen this before and this is so
crazy I'm sitting next to the bird snake
guy this is what I've questions on like
what was the setup on this so they had a
seated harness and they had two wires on
the hips okay going out and being out
and there were two guys just working for
oh and then I was doing a split are you
sure this not had a best harness and the
pick was on my upper back end the whole
could think that was all improv you know
do something you know ridiculous so good
even the tongue thing you do is like
perfect either not my student absolute
joy nothing you got to show your wisdoms
a show that's been incredible and I love
getting to watching this awesome fight
scenes if you guys want to keep up with
the other arm you can follow them on
Instagram and either I'm joy the text is
on the screen here all the link in the
description below and you guys can hit
me up too you have any questions watch
out hi you might be asking yourself Jake
what are you doing are you wearing a
standard stunt man's uniform yes I am
because today I am here to film my very
own stunt rail courtesy of today's
sponsor Skillshare I've been teaching
myself the art of film and video and
photography in order to craft the
perfect stunt real guys Skillshare is an
online learning community that offers
never sits with me meaning because it
empowers you to
they empower you to grow because they're
designed for real life meaning you don't
have to put your life on hold like
learning how to be a professional
stuntman no you can rise to the
challenge
to learn something new in your free time
guys now in my journey to learn about
the perfect stun reel
I studied classes in films video
marketing and photography one of my
favorites was one called cinematography
basics understanding filmmaking style
just like in film there's a style to
every stunt that you're doing quick guys
compared to other courses what do you
think about skills here it's actually
incredibly affordable an annual
membership is just under ten bucks a
month I mean think about where you're
gonna learn how to do this
[Music]
guys wait twenty twenty thirty years to
discover something about yourself I
learned something now I know most people
don't say it every January of every year
that you're gonna do something new and
different this year
but think about if you go to the link in
the description below you'll get two
months a premium membership now we're
not gonna offer that every January so
I'd get in gear
[Music]